[Musique]
c'est très sympa tout le monde sait
faire ça oui ma faim on peut les faire
plus ou moins bien on commence par de la
vanille ton cela ronde du seul de grosse
pincée ou quatre petites pêches du sucre
je vais mettre environ 4 cuillerées à
gauche vous voyez ça comme ça oui
fukuda et puis un quart de litre de lait
environ la farine noyau je vais la
placer en pluie que je vais en mettre
environ 400 noir de l'huile voyez-vous
qu'environ 2 cuillerées à soupe des jeux
je vais en mettre une
8 c'est à peu près ce que ça peut
absorber mais si par hasard il en faut
davantage
ne pas hésiter à l'humain pourtant et
quelques minutes pour qu'elle soit bien
bien risque est le souffle un petit peu
molle et les vanilles vallier et lequel
est très très chaud préparé quelques
centaines de grammes environ
écoutez en mars il est fondu je vais
donc me mélanger en deux ou trois fois
voilà ma nous allons ajouter le parfum
car la régie
dany n'est ce pas là il faut en mettre
beaucoup et c'est du rhône qui rentre
comme partant principal rouge en mai
environ 6 3 3 6 ou deux fois plus que je
né me dany c'est à dire un tiers environ
a ni deux tiers de rome en tout et en
tout ça doit donner un très grand verre
à vin un très grand vin de bordeaux
c'est à dire pas loin d'un quart de
litre et maintenant j'obtiens une pâte
qui est très liquide dit non non elle
n'est pas encore assez elle les villes
rendrait pas tout à fait assez
alors je vais la détendre c'est à dire
l'allongé avec la bière alors là conclut
thierry beer de la bm
frêche doit être ni chaud ni froid dans
l'histoire la pâte doit toujours être
légèrement légèrement tiède en quelque
sorte on n'est pas beaucoup et vous
voyez vous voilà j'ai mis maintenant sur
pied ou qui ne passent relativement
clair nous sommes presque pas tout à
fait une fois encore mettre un tout
petit peu de jeu bien voilà c'est bien
maintenant nous sommes prêts à faire les
choeurs combien de personnes il y en a
pour quatre personnes à condition d'en
manger 24 août entre chacune voilà là
nous sommes prêts on doit aller pleurer
on n'a rien mettre dedans
aboyer sur les amènera dans la farine de
l'eau en faire deux trois ans n'est pas
comme ceux ci ont les retours et là
elles vont être tout de suite oui on
peut le maintenir en place et continuer
en faire d'autres violences bandits
sympathie on peut en manger des
quantités de crack consoles sont pas
grâce de son sèche
je pense que cette recette va plaire à
nos spectateurs qui n'ont pas de fous en
tout cas c'est très simple à affaires
voyez vous pas
[Musique]